we'll get to some sketches now real
sketches levi are you here leave i'll
have to know the d why don't we do the
house plane right do you remember the
sand
no
the plant kills why don't we why don't
we why don't we explore in real time
what's the setup you'll see
[Music]
hey conor o'brien here for another
edition of behind the nonsense this is
where we review
some sketches uh that we love to think
about talk about remember
and uh we do it with uh the people that
help make them happen and today andy and
i are sitting with levi mcdougall
uh and um this is a sketch that you
wrote
i don't want to give anything away but
um
i don't know it just i just saw it for
the first time since we aired it so i'd
completely forgotten it and it really
made me laugh you wrote it with todd
levitt
you wrote this with todd levin todd
levin levi mcdougall the lennon
mccartney of
the beatles thank you take a look
a team of botany professors from the
university of western australia just
released a study true story that reveals
plants have long-term memory
yeah wait is that really true this is an
absolutely true story and according to
the study
plants can actually remember being
harmed they have a memory of being
harmed
huh
they say plants can even remember
something for several weeks imagine if
this whole time plants were watching our
behavior and remembering everything
isn't that weird andy
andy
[Music]
i can't take any chances
you gotta die little tree you gotta die
die
sorry pal
[Music]
no witnesses
so
[Applause]
sorry sorry i had a
bathroom emergency
no problem mandy no problem at all
wow i have to say that is a sketch i
completely forgot and just was watching
it now and um really it made me happy
yeah it's so funny it's my favorite kind
of sketch it's completely completely
insane and silly what i love about it is
i like um there's so many things but
early in comedy career you can be
thinking that you need to kind of make
things sort of make sense and then you
realize no you really don't right so
there has to be some internal logic at
least on our show yeah but
but you you realize that
okay andy has done some horrible thing
we will never find out what it is and
but then there's so many things in there
like uh the blood
that comes shooting that
is inside a plant when you shoot it
really makes me happy and then uh
i love the plant getting in a car
taking off and then it's that thing you
see in movies a million times you
clearly would get in your car
but you're easily 40 seconds behind
but no you're immediately right behind
it right and then of course the insanity
of going over the cliff and the gun the
plant's gun shooting around the corner
that was really a nice gimmick really
nicely shot and uh and apparently this
went through some kind of change yeah
the first cut of it that we did in
rehearsal it went great but it ended
after the bloodshot so it went killing
the plant and then the bloodshot was
like the extreme thing that ended it but
it went so well that i remember we cut
back to you and you were you were
laughing you're like oh i wanted to keep
going yeah and then there was a
conversation like no let's really like
we could show it like this but it could
go so much further so the next day
we shot the chase
where the third plant slips away and you
see its leaf
go under and this was one of the first
times i was still pretty new to the show
that it really felt like we were on a
movie a lot because there were you were
driving your own car and we were doing
like a little chase on a wide street and
they had security clearing the way
and you know you're seeing the tours go
around telling you about all the yeah
yeah and we were doing one for our show
yeah being on the warner brothers lot we
could go to a new york street we could
go to the jungle we could go to you know
a town square you know they were just
literally a
five-minute golf cart right away it's
sort of a good lesson
that sometimes you see something and you
think oh that's perfectly fine that
could have ended with the blood yeah but
let's give them more than they think
they're gonna get yeah and that means
waiting a day or two days so let's not i
love that piece and we could have used
it probably that night but let's wait
because
i always remember being whatever i was
12 13 14 and seeing sc tv and seeing
something
go here then here then here then all the
way over there and being just blown away
and
you can't do that all the time but when
you see an opportunity to do it yeah
take the time
hold it
add that next part yeah and um it's so
satisfying it's also good to listen to
like your instincts having you know
especially the two of us having sat
there and looked at a zillion sketches
and to have the feeling of i want more
and to then follow say like yeah that's
enough but i want more like yeah let's
see more how far yeah especially
washington's like what a bummer it would
have been to have not gone that yeah
yeah sorry yeah
but it's the same thing it's like i you
know there's so many times when there
will be a sketch and it's like there's a
feeling it should end there like even
though you know like you just yeah you
you there's a rhythm and an instinct
that you get but now i see it and i
think it could go further yeah yeah yeah
like like andy could be there it's gonna
come back yeah the lights survive the
correct it's burning it's burned and one
of its one of its stalks is in a sling
yeah and it puts a knife through andy's
back but um that's for another time
we'll do that next time yeah or it comes
with two plant cops yeah cops the plant
cops arrest me it's a new mayor of east
town yeah yeah yeah exactly there you go
could be the new mayor of east town
parity which we couldn't do then because
that show didn't exist and a plant can't
learn
a bad philadelphia accent right at that
point in time at that point in time
[Music]
great all right all right now levi get
the [ __ ] out i'm leaving thanks for
learning my last name mcdougall left a
note the day that levi left that chat if
i'd known you were scots i would never
have let you work here